the movie is set in a post-apocalyptic
World which has been ravaged by a deadly
virus both men and women can contract
and carry the virus but mysteriously it
is only killing women it is created
Mayhem all over the world and scientists
are struggling to find a cure the virus
is very strange as it didn't originate
from organisms but rather it fell to
Earth in the form of Ash the entire
world is bombarded with this strange Ash
which has appeared literally out of thin
air as the months pass by the female
population is depleting at a rapid rate
hence threatening an Extinction and
since women can contract the virus from
men living in their vicinity the
governments around the world have
started a campaign in this campaign the
women are relocated to an isolation camp
with the promise to keep them safe but
in reality they are forced to the camp
where various cruel and painful tests
are conducted on them to find the actual
nature of the virus as a result woman
has become an extremely rare species to
put it into context a huge reward of
millions is awarded to the one who Who
can capture a live woman and hand them
over to the government then we are taken
to a quarantine Department which is
rented by a guy named William at first
it looks like any other apartment but
soon we get to know that a female named
Eva is also living there she is none
other than William's girlfriend it turns
out Eva has managed to survive so far
because Willis hid her well from the
authorities he doesn't allow her to go
outside or use the phone even if it's
for her own good Wills take control over
her freedom and movement has had a
negative impact on the couple's
relationship with each passing day Eva
feels more and more suffocated in her
apartment she is desperate to go outside
and feel the sun on the 400th day Eva
reaches her Breaking Point she covertly
puts on a hazmat suit and runs up to the
roof of their building soon will notices
her and runs after her however before he
can stop her and get her back Eva rips
off her suit and allows herself to be
infected by the ash for her living under
quarantine and watching millions of
people get picked off by a mysterious
virus just wasn't a life she wanted to
to live will eventually convinces her to
return home but it's clear that they are
fed up with each other Eva takes off her
hazmat suit and heads into the shower
while will breaks down on the couch
after cleaning the dirt off of her Eva
takes out a kid and takes a swab test to
check if she's really contracted the
virus as they wait for the result the
couple hear multiple police cars show up
outside their home it's clear that their
home is being raided and despite their
recent argument will rushes Eva to her
room and helps her hide inside the bed
following this he lets the cops into the
house they search the place for a while
and then interrogate will about his
identity here it's revealed that the
apartment was actually rented by Eva and
her late friend Carolyn who lost her
life to the virus will confidently says
that Carolyn was his girlfriend and that
he built the meticulous quarantine to
keep her safe the police then ask him
about Eva to which he lies that she has
been missing since the virus struck
after a while the cops are finally
convinced that there are no women in the
apartment and they proceed to leave but
as the armed men exit one of them hangs
back and reveals that he know Eva is
here with him it turns out the policeman
spotted the swab test that Eva forgot on
the table the test is positive meaning
Eva has caught the virus however he
pities the couple and decides not to
alert his colleagues about her before
leaving he tells will to enjoy his last
few days with her will is heartbroken
but he is forced to collect himself as
the apartment is no longer safe moreover
Eva wants to escape the city as her
secluded lifestyle and overall isolation
has almost driven her insane shortly
after the two quickly packed their
belongings and abandoned the apartment
Eva dresses up as a man and on their way
out of the city they pull over at a
convenience store unsurprisingly the
tampons have been made free as there are
virtually no women left in the world
anymore you would think that they'd just
burn them since men are scared of
tampons but his Eva covertly tries to
take some tampons the store clerk
catches her in the ACT he has taken
aback to see a woman after a long long
time when Eva starts panicking will
brings out his gun and threatens the man
to keep his mouth shut and after the man
lies on the ground to surrender the
couple out of the store as they drive
away the movie flashes back to the past
to when everything was normal on the TV
a News Channel reports that a rare comet
is set to take a journey close to Earth
meanwhile will has recently moved into
Eva's apartment after years of dating
one day as the two spend some quality
time alone some mysterious snow-like
substances start falling from the sky
the couple is shocked as winter is still
far away but when they peek through the
window they realize that it's Ash just
then Eva's best friend Carolyn returns
home covered in it she tries to say
something but soon gets dizzy and
collapses on the ground back in the
present will and Eva pull over at a
motel there they noticed some sketchy
looking men with rifles in one of the
rooms however the couple ignores them
and spends the night at the same Motel
the next day before heading into the
woods Eva insists on having her last
cooked meal at a restaurant will
reluctantly agrees and they stop by a
nearby Diner there the TV reports that
scientists at the U.S Center for rebirth
and repopulation have created an
artificial embryo late latest trials
have seen the fetus survive up to one
month which is a historical achievement
in itself many world leaders have
praised the achievement as this could be
the most probable way of repopulation
once the cure to the hnv21 virus is
found the news also reports that the
federal government has increased the
reward for reporting or locating live
American females to 2 million dollars as
everyone is hooked to the TV the sketchy
men from the motel arrive at the diner
and are elated by the news to make
matters worse for the couple Eva
suddenly starts bleeding from her ear
indicating that her impending demise is
nearing when will notices this he
hurries her out of the diner without
even paying the bill unfortunately this
attracts the attention of a man Arthur
and his teenage son Casey both of whom
notice that Eva is a woman disguised as
a man shortly after Eva begins
hemorrhaging prompting will to panic as
it's the first stage of the infection
cycle in frustration he starts reading
the entire cycle to Eva causing her to
get angry hence she orders him to stop
the car and then runs into the nearby
bushes however when she reaches a bit
further further she becomes exhausted
and starts crying after some time she
returns and the couple continue their
Journey soon they Venture into the woods
in search of their final destination
which turns out to be a secret waterfall
will is distraught by the thought of
losing the love of his life but on the
other hand Eva is trying to be as
cheerful as possible wanting to make the
most of their final moments together the
movie again cuts back to the Past after
Carolyn is fainted due to her contact
with the Ash will indiva immediately
rush her to the hospital but soon she is
declared dead as the couple wanders
around the place devastated they realize
that only women are being infected by
this mysterious sickness realizing that
his wife's life may be in danger Will
sneaks into a prohibited room in the
hospital and steals two hazmat suits so
that they can protect themselves from
the ash then through the back entrance
they run away once they return home they
call Eva's father Mahesh who happens to
be a doctor Mahesh reveals that even at
his place the ashes wreaked havoc and
thousands of women have already died he
then suggests the couple set up a
quarantine and will immediately gets to
work he starts securing the house with
Furniture germ resistant plastic and
various other safety elements Eva is
very nonchalant about the security
measures while well is more serious and
careful about everything he stays up all
night to boil water and in the morning
he goes to the store to fetch packaged
food he also sets up ultraviolet lights
around the house that allegedly kill
pathogens and germs within a couple of
feet moreover he always stays away from
Eva knowing that he can transmit the
disease to her several months pass by
but the virus continues to claim more
and more lives eventually the government
requests all women check themselves into
government-controlled medical facilities
for the embryo project which apparently
intends to find a way to repopulate the
Earth the government-controlled media
tries to paint a Rosy picture of the
detention centers but the internet is
soon flooded with conspiracy theories
about horrible experiments being
conducted on women therefore will
refuses to hand Eva over to the
government and he builds a bed where she
can hide from the authorities as a
precautionary measure over the course of
the next few months will becomes
extremely paranoid and one by one he
seizes all of Eva's freedoms he even
forbids her from using her phone fearing
that the government is listening to them
with no one else to talk to Eva turns to
a Secret all-female online Forum to keep
herself company will again tries to stop
her from using the Forum but she refuses
to listen as the female survivors in the
chat are her only support system
unfortunately the survivors in the chat
also continue to dwindle in number
giving Eva a sense of hopelessness and
despair back in the present will and
Diva walk for hours and along the way
the latter continues to take pictures on
her camera at night they light a fire
and set up a camp evil Longs for
intimacy and she asks Will's help in
taking off the duct tape she tied around
her chest in order to pass off as a man
however will is cold and distant and
after helping her he returns back to his
tent the next day they continue their
journey and Eva continues to try to
cheer her boyfriend up will finally
begins to lighten up and he teaches Eva
how to shoot on the other hand we see
the Father's son Duo from earlier Arthur
and Casey driving in the woods they want
to claim the 2 million reward by
capturing Eva and it turns out they have
followed the couple into the forest
using the map they left at the diner
soon the two also Venture into the
forest armed with rifles at night event
will again set up a camp and as they
proceed to make love she unexpectedly
suffers from seizures and convulsions
springing into action will cushions her
head and helps her relax the next day
Eva wakes up early to fetch some water
from the river however when she returns
she notices Arthur and Casey holding
will hostage from a distance they have
tied him up tightly against a tree
shortly after Arthur eventually locates
Eva and chases her but she manages to
escape left with no choice the
father-son duo continues to hold will
hostage in hopes that evil will return
for his sake at night Casey stands guard
with a rifle while his father sleeps Eva
conjures a plan of her own and in the
dead of night she shows up undressed she
seductively approaches Casey the teenage
boy is still broken over his
girlfriend's death and having not seen a
woman for over a year he gets distracted
by her beauty this allows Eva to knock
him out cold after this she frees Arthur
from the tree and wasting no time he
takes the rifle and shoots Arthur to
Death In His tent the movie then again
cuts back to the past it's Day 400 since
everything went Bleak Eva has several
missed calls from her father on her
phone this worries her as they had
agreed not to call each other on the
phone due to security measures realizing
that something wrong has happened she
insists on speaking to her father but
will only agrees on a video call with
the camera and mic disabled on the call
Eva's distraught father reveals that the
government took her mother despite her
being over 60 years old he then breaks
into tears and expresses his wish to see
his daughter but when an emotional Eva
attempts to turn on the camera and Mike
Will intervenes and hangs up the call as
a result the bereaved Eva loses it and
she lashes out at him for keeping her
trapped she then holds him at gunpoint
and orders him to go away forever after
will reluctantly leaves even notices a
visual of the waterfall on her laptop it
reminds her of Tranquility love and
freedom so she decides to venture out
she puts on the Hazmat suit and rushes
to the roof of the apartment complex
back in the present will and Diva
continue their journey and they
eventually make it to the secret
waterfall there the couple Embraces each
other knowing that they'll always be
soul mates will kisses her and she snaps
a selfie prepared to die as she bleeds
out losing energy but in an atmosphere
of happiness and relief Eva feels that
she was burdening well and as she awaits
her death she smiles knowing that her
beloved can soon go on to live a proper
life see you tomorrow guys I'm gonna go
take a cold shower now subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching